la verdad es que los que nos dedicamos a
trabajar para los públicos de la cultura
y con los públicos de la cultura también
en una disciplina que ha puesto vamos a
denominar creación y desarrollo de
audiencias
acabamos adquiriendo una inevitable
querencia hacia el voyeurismo lo
confieso especialmente en prácticas
culturales presenciales nos encanta a mí
al menos prestar atención a cómo
reacciona el público ante lo que pasa en
un determinado escenario a ver cómo se
relacionan entre sí antes durante y
después a saber si esa experiencia ha
sido grata si ha sido satisfactoria y
obviamente si le recomendarían a alguien
o no y en mi caso como decía antes por
deformación profesional seguro en
ocasiones esto incluso me genera
problemas de recepción como público
porque acabas estando más pendiente de
lo que les pasa a los demás que lo que
me pasa a mí mismo y lo que pasa en el
escenario
en cualquier caso
y respondiendo a tu pregunta en una
situación de pandemia global como la que
estamos viviendo ahora mismo
mi obsesión es especialmente atender a
cual está siendo esa reacción esa
actitud de la ciudadanía ante por una
parte asistir al cierre y en
operatividad de los espacios habituales
de la cultura museos bibliotecas teatros
auditorios cines pero por otra parte y
entraremos luego en más detalle en ello
a tener un acceso a través de internet a
una ingente cantidad de propuestas de
actividades de recursos vinculados al
arte la cultura que nos acompañan
obviamente y que nos hacen mucho más
digerible este confinamiento
lo que resulta más incierto obviamente
es vislumbrar adivinar qué es lo que
pasará ese día después qué consecuencias
sufrirá la práctica cultural cuando ésta
acabe y volvamos a una nueva normalidad
yo creo que hay cuatro ítems que
condicionarán esa relación de los
currículos a la cultura en un futuro no
muy lejano primer ítem la participación
cultural
llevamos bastantes años trabajando
intensamente por la democratización de
la cultura por asegurar el acceso
universal de la cultura por eliminar
barreras de accesibilidad de todo tipo
pero en paralelo hemos ido trabajando
también la democracia cultural es decir
posibilitar que la ciudadanía sea
participe yo creo que acceso y
participación están siendo dos
constantes en este momento a lo largo de
estos días y que nos permiten pensar en
un cierto auge de el protagonismo de la
ciudadanía en la cultura a la formación
a la autoformación a una mayor
disposición a participar y ser
partícipes como individuos y como
comunidades de la cultura
segundo ítem la relación entre educación
salud y cultura
más que nunca educación y cultura
deberán ir de la mano incluso
encontrando territorios compartidos lo
que está claro es que son vasos
comunicantes y creo que más allá de las
decisiones políticas que hay al respecto
la ciudadanía las percibe como tales
hablaba también de la relación con entre
salud y cultura porque yo creo que
cobrarán cada vez más importancia a
proyectos programas que contemplen la
cultura como un elemento de salud y de
bienestar tanto física como emocional
pienso por ejemplo en proyectos que ya
se están desarrollando que intentan
combatir la soledad no voluntaria de
nuestros mayores y aprovechando a través
del arte de la cultura como generar
una mayor relación entre las personas y
una posibilitando la sociabilidad creo
que es importante tercer elemento quizás
el más obvio de todos el mundo online
si hasta ahora desde la cultura decimos
que nuestro amigo era netflix o el for
night ahora hemos entendido claramente
el porqué hemos probado jugar en su
territorio
hemos generado compartido volcado mil y
una propuestas y recursos en internet de
todo tipo y hemos visto que la recepción
además era extraordinaria pero ojo
la calidad en muchos casos no era la
óptima
y en otros la verdad es que esa no
calidad
incluso producía un valor añadido pues
permitía compartir esa espontaneidad o
vivir momentos únicos remarcando la
relación incluso directa entre creador
artista y públicos pero lo que nos ha
dejado clarísimo es ver qué proyectos
culturales ya estaban preparados para
estar presentes en el mundo online con
un pensamiento estratégico previo y
cuáles no yo creo que el futuro
inmediato sin duda la interacción entre
lo presencial y el online serán
preponderantes de nuevo antes durante y
después habrá combinaciones y eso nos
permitirá experimentar formatos repensar
el diseño de esas experiencias
culturales y duraciones diseño de
espacios la propia accesibilidad y
encontrar territorios híbridos en los
que convivirán de todas maneras me
gustaría remarcar que cuando pensemos en
el famoso concepto de transformación
digital creo que debemos poner énfasis
en la transformación en el cambio
estratégico lo digital yo creo que ya se
nos supone
y cuarto y en cuatro cuarto elemento yo
creo que es derivado de la anterior por
tremendamente importante y es la
monetización
no cabe duda que el sector artístico y
cultural igual que la mayoría de
sectores
está siendo tremendamente generoso ha
captado claramente la necesidad de la
ciudadanía de aprender de conocer de
descubrir de disfrutar de crear e
incluso de entretenerse por supuesto
pero la cultura no es un lujo es una
necesidad vital y yo creo que ahora nos
damos cuenta cuando nos falta que no
podemos prescindir de ella
pero ello no comporta que la cultura la
asociados a gratuidad no debemos olvidar
que detrás existen muchísimos
profesionales de funciones absolutamente
diversas hay todo un ecosistema
muchísimas empresas pequeñas medianas y
grandes que viven o intentan vivir de la
arte y de la cultura
por tanto participación relación entre
educación salud y cultura el mundo
online el mundo virtual y monetización
cuatro ítems que como sector nos hemos
de replantear y aprovechar yo quiero
este momento de tremenda incertidumbre
para todos para hacer reset para
repensarnos como proyecto y como sector
y para replantearnos nuestro modelo de
negocio y nuestra oferta de productos y
de servicios y a ser posible de una
manera sistémica hablaba de ecosistema
pues pensando en red colaborando entre
nosotros y sobre todo trabajando
relevantes para nuestros públicos es
decir poniendo a los públicos en el
verdadero eje estratégico en el centro
de nuestra estrategia como sector
supongo que de mar inmediata lo primero
que nos tocará es agradecer como la
mayoría a tantos profesionales de
sectores vinculados a la salud a la
educación
al abastecimiento a la seguridad bueno
de hecho ya lo hacemos cada día
aplaudiéndole es importante esto del
aplauso para el sector cultural pero
aplaudiéndoles desde nuestros balcones
pero por supuesto también cuando
volvamos a ese reencuentro en nuestras
calles y plazas pero también en nuestros
museos en nuestras bibliotecas nuestros
cines teatros auditorios ofreciéndoles
lo mejor de nosotros mismos seguir
buscando ese reencuentro entre entre
público y creación entre arte con el
arte y la cultura
seremos conscientes sin duda de que las
circunstancias habrán cambiado habrá un
impacto emocional
obvio habrá una pérdida de capacidad
adquisitiva a restricciones de movilidad
de las personas y accesibilidad pero el
día después ese día después el sector de
la cultura estará allí sin duda con los
brazos abiertos generando confianza y
sobre todo haciendo pedagogía positiva
por poner en valor la cultura porque en
definitiva y estoy convencido de ello al
final del túnel escucharemos una dulce
melodía la de los aplausos de los
públicos que también estarán allí sin
duda probablemente de otra manera como
hemos dicho pero los públicos nos
seguirán esperando más que nunca salud y
cultura